en la región brasileña de pernambuco
María da Silva abre la nevera de su casa
y rompen llanto al verla vacía esta
viuda de 58 años es el reflejo de muchos
en Brasil como principal sostén de su
familia tiene que luchar para alimentar
a sus siete hijos y nietos
estamos sufriendo y no es ninguna broma
mis hijos salen a las calles para
intentar ayudarme mendigan todos
nuestros amigos nos ayudan
sin baño agua ni electricidad da Silva y
su familia están entre los más de 33
millones de personas que pasan hambre en
Brasil una cifra que ha aumentado en un
73% en los últimos dos años y que es uno
de los focos de la actual campaña
política de las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre el ex
presidente y favorito según las
encuestas Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
culpa al presidente Jair bolsonaro por
esta situación Ya que en 2014 Brasil
salió del mapa del hambre de Naciones
Unidas bajo el mandato de Lula
nosotros garantizamos que 33 millones de
brasileños podrán tomar café almorzar y
cenar cada día o morirán de hambre
pero a pesar de que Lula y su programa
de izquierda gozan de gran apoyo en la
región del nordeste donde nació muchos
Allí se sienten abandonados por todas
las opciones políticas
se acuerdan de los pobres en época
electoral Pero el día siguiente se
olvidan de ellos
esa es la realidad de la vida insertados
algo por lo que los ciudadanos de esta
región la más pobre del país pide más
presencia y Amparo del estado